Hey, Vsauce.
Michael here.
And I'm in Los Angeles, but today we're going
to talk about love.
You can't buy love, but what if you could?
I mean, what if I had a machine that could
make you fall in love with someone for the
rest of your life?
What should I charge for the use of that machine?
Well, we should, first of all, be clear about
what we mean when we say "love."
I'm not talking about the love you have for
your BFFs or your love for your family or
your love of learning.
I'm also not talking about lust, an immediate
attraction we have towards other people mediated
by hormones like testosterone and oestrogen.
I'm talking about what happens later, when
you begin to associate an immediate reward
with one other person - what we call passionate
love.
This is what you see in new couples, where
they wanna be with each other and are almost
obsessed with each other.
Well psychologists have a really great term
for that kind of love.
They call it limerence.
That's right.
Whenever you're in this state and you do things
like wake up super early to get a bagel with
the person and even though you're gonna miss
class just because you wanna see them that
badly, you're exhibiting limerent behaviour.
Okay, that sounds great.
But if I wanna sell love, I'm gonna have to
find a way to measure it and it turns out
to be quite a difficult task.
We do have a tool called the passionate love
survey.
It was developed by psychologists and it's
been found to be quite reliable when it comes
to analysing other behaviours we associate
with passionate love.
For instance, we found, using the survey,
that men and women both experience the same
amounts of passionate love when they're in
a relationship.
We've also found that men tend to fall in
the love faster and sooner than women, who
appear to be more cautious.
But we're here to talk about money.
Interestingly, a UK study once looked at people
who heard that someone else loved them.
They heard the phrase "I love you" for the
first time and they took the amount of happiness
those people felt and compared it to the amount
of happiness gamblers feel when they win large
sums of money.
Their conclusion, that hearing that someone
loves you for the first time is the equivalent
happiness level of receiving 267,000 dollars.
But when you go beyond passionate love to
committed long-term love, there's all kinds
of practical benefits marriage brings.
In fact, it's been estimated that tax breaks
and health care costs all together mean that
being married is the equivalent of receiving
an extra 100,000 dollars a year.
Now we have a lot of ways of visualizing the
effect having money has on a person.
For instance, we know that in wealthier countries
people report feeling respect more often.
They also report eating tastier foods, for
instance.
But here's what's really awesome.
Take a look at the graph of wealth against
love.
It doesn't matter.
Love is democratic, no matter who you are
or how much money you have, people all over
the world are feeling it.
It should be noted that having more money
does not necessarily equate to being more
happy.
This is what's known as the hedonistic treadmill.
Getting more money helps with happiness, but
only up to a certain point.
In United States that point is about 75,000
dollars a year.
At that point, more money has diminishing
returns on how happy it makes you.
Another thing that correlates to having more
money, more wealth, is living longer, having
a larger life expectancy.
But you know what else correlates to living
longer?
Love.
But not just passionate love, the kind of
love that follows it - committed, long-term
love.
In fact, people who form life-long pair bonds
with another person live, on average, 15%
longer.
So if you wanna be really non-hard-scienc-y
about it, all other things being equal and
assuming that you're not already super super
rich, finding a pair bond, finding a relationship
that lasts for life is the equivalent of making
about an extra 30 to 40 thousand dollars a
year.
Now, like I said, that's not hard science,
but you know what is?
Vasopressin and oxytocin, the chemicals that
are exuded in people's brains when they
look at photos of people that they formed
committed, long-term relationships with.
These chemicals are incredible.
We've also seen elevated levels of them in
dogs that have been pet for really long time.
And we also know that couples who receive
high levels of these chemicals resolve conflicts
faster.
And, people who struggle to produce these
chemicals in their brain have a similar struggle
when it comes to forming long-term relationships.
In fact, you can raise your levels of oxytocin
or vasopressin inside your own brain by simply
looking into someone else's eyes.
That's right.
So, in a way, looking into the eyes of somebody
that you like is the administration of a psycho-active
drug that's addictive and the long-term consequences
are living longer.
Thanks for watching.